[Music]
being trans is not that hard is being
trans in a world that doesn't like trans
people that is hard transphobia is hard
we're such a small community like we
can't fight this battle ourselves when I
do people's nails
it's about hoping that people go away
with more than a manicure they go away
and Ally
[Music]
I'm Charlie crags and I'm a trans
activist and author
now transphobia is a campaign Iran bribe
travel around the UK will pop up nail
salon and I offer the public free nails
so for the chances down and have a chat
of a trans person when people sit down
and get their nails done by me that's my
way of showing that trans people are
just human as a child and knew that I
was different and I knew that I felt
like a girl I've really tried to repress
it and I was so angry at myself for
being feminine I want to be like the
boys in school so I wouldn't be bullied
anymore I'm Irish working-class Catholic
I had a lot of cards stacked against me
and I was like it might be hard
transitioning but I'm gonna kill myself
if I don't my life became a lot lot
harder when I came out as trans in a way
I didn't even anticipate and my early
transition after a night out I was at a
packed bus stop these guys came over I
saw one of them look at me he was like
trying to flirt with me I could tell he
didn't realize I was trans and then he
was like oh my god that's a man he like
grabbed my boobs and then it kind of
became a bit more physical
after it was done I'm a mess knowing
what came over and asked me I'm okay no
one looked at me and I was done and that
I don't know but that's like it just
really showed me like what people think
of me it really really hurt that no one
asked if I was okay I just realized I
was like we need allies not just in the
fight for our rights but then find that
saw every day lies when I started the
campaign five years ago I was like why
isn't one aware of how hard it is to be
trans how much abuse I'm getting and the
fact that when I transitioned my chance
of being murdered when I was one in
twelve what I do with no transphobia is
about humanizing issue I hire other
trans people to come to do nails with me
you're getting a different stories and
different narratives it's about sitting
down one-on-one person-to-person holding
hands like you can't get more human if I
was a sit there with a table full of
brochures about trans before they're not
gonna interact whereas if I'm offering
nails
people love a free manicure people are
gonna be interested I want to reach that
straight boy who has never met a trans
person or even an LGBTQ person before I
want to reach the old lady who doesn't
even know what LGBT means so that if
they're out and they see someone being
attacked they might say something
because then they have that emotional
link most times people will ask the
wrong question but it's the perfect time
to ask that wrong question
I brought Oh babes we don't ask that
yell I've explained why I'd explained in
a nice way in an accessible way I've
done probably 10,000 conversations and
to know that like they're on side now
they go where they love me like they're
like oh yeah you've really changed my
mind about this and to think that they
will now raise their kids to be like
decent non transphobic people you know
that's so exciting to me knowing that
like ripples make waves and you've put
an ally out into the world and allies
make other allies
[Music]
it really makes me happy to know that
trans people won't have to all go
through the same thing that I went
through I took the negative and I tell
it something positive and I feel like
that is often the only way to get
through life I'm very proud to be trans
someone's God
[Music]
you